learners permit thursdays on my youtube
subscribe today the night pants nation
tour is underway cleveland you are up
next december 9th through the 11th la
jolla you're right after that december
17th through the 19th and austin we're
kicking off 2022 down there january 6th
through the 8th get your tickets now at
ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pass
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media
can't tell you uh how um grateful i am
that so many of you are coming out to
see me on tour if you're available if
you got the money and you're home when
i'm in your town come on out and see the
night pants nation tour tickets
available ryanstickler.com
sign up for the email list uh you'll be
the first to know all kinds of inside
stuff um and thank you again this show
continues to grow and uh it blows me
away so if you're watching out there hit
that subscribe it means nothing to you
and everything to me trust me when i
tell you that the patreon
every month it grows uh the honeydew
with y'all i'm highlighting the
lowlights with y'all if you or someone
you know has this story it has to be
heard please submit it to
honeydewpodcast gmail.com
we'll hopefully get to do an episode
together it's five bucks a month all
right if you sign up for a year you get
over a month free and you're getting the
honey do a day early ad free all right
i'm doing everything i can to keep the
costs low and keep the content coming
y'all check out learner's permit out
there with my stepson risking my life
for content guys risk in my life to
teach these young kids uh
how to navigate the highways and byways
of life uh you know what we do over here
i love my job we highlight the low
lights y'all and uh these are the
stories behind the storytellers i'm very
excited to have this storyteller back on
the do ladies and gentlemen thomas
dopezyola welcome back to the honeydew
bro sir thank you thank you thank you
for having me thank you for being back
i'm ready
yeah well what i'm very excited about is
uh the first time you did this show was
the first time you had done anything
like that which i i forgot about that i
forgot it was the first time we've done
anything and now since then you've
launched your own podcast you're getting
coming up on a year in
yeah we're getting close it happens
quick it was fast as hell actually um so
why don't you plug everything first and
then we're going to get into the story
so basically it's dope as usual podcast
marty you know jurassic graphics and i
have been doing it we started in
february and
it's just been going strong man
everything's working out well um
people are watching everything's growing
guests are coming
sponsorships which blows my [__] mind
because you know doing weed content for
so long there are no sponsorships you
get you don't get paid right now that
we're
marty and i go into an episode going oh
we got paid for this
it's a whole different mindset and game
plan when i start investing everything
in so that's what we've been doing since
the last time i was here is the dope as
usual podcast
that's really it man just non-stop every
every monday same time three o'clock
it's fun well hopefully it continues to
change you know they i believe youtube
had had banned alcohol for a while and
now's allowing alcohol so hopefully
they'll
they'll come around eventually once
marijuana is federally legal you
everybody has to be person's going to
pounce on it for that penny it has to be
man i don't get paid they show me how
much money i would get paid on that
channel oh they show you that it's a lot
and i don't get it it's a great bar they
show you it yeah it's uh it's not
highlighted
you know what i'm saying it's like a
dull grain here's what you should be
getting oh i see it i can google it they
still make their money though yeah i'd
get ads on it all day well um
i wanted to say you know i hear a lot
people people hit me up and say i'm like
a joey diaz i'm like and i'm like
there's no you're not
but
i do hear from the comments because this
was an interesting crossover the first
time we did it and uh i get a lot of uh
you're like a young joey diaz stories i
hear that a lot too and you know joey's
58 now i think so you got plenty of time
to to be a middle-aged they had a whole
joey yes too you got off to quite a
start that's a lot of catching up to do
man i want to reintroduce you uh your
story at least your background so
um i do forget what happened with your
biological father
oh my dad's cool i just saw him last
week okay he's he's in the picture yeah
so your mom and dad split
my mom and dad had been splitting since
i was three and the step dad comes in at
what age my stepdad um
i think i was nine okay and and describe
again who your stepdad is in your life
okay because after i left last time i
realized how ridiculous it really sounds
and then i tell people my family that i
talked about it and they go yeah it's
regular so my stepdad my mom
my mom's mom is jewish lady and my
mom's dad was a spanish guy from texas
very weird mix
and
my mom's a jerk
and she dates people based on can i piss
my own mom off that's how i felt because
my mom had me young my sister was 16
when she had her had me at just turning
18. wow so she was in high school 16.
she was a mom yeah my mom's
she's [__] wild and
she marries this guy i mean we'll always
never say his name but
i saw axel rose that's what he looked
like to me okay he had hair down to
almost his knee he had a flannel on and
he was playing hacky sack and at the
time i played hacky sack and he could do
the rainbow where it goes over your head
so i thought well this is the coolest
[__] i ever met in my life and
my dad sucked at the time he was on
crank
so you know it was a guy around me and
most my mom my sister so
he sounds cool but
he is cool he's just a straight white
supremacist
it's it's it's unbelievable
it's unbelievable but also
a white supremacist who taught you
spanish spanish yeah it's pretty funny
and your mom's a jewish well her mom's a
jewish lady it's insane it's
unbelievable it is it's stupid and you
grow up in that environment not knowing
that that's
not normal until when
uh
because then i thought about it
i already had it hard man i don't speak
spanish and i'm brown
and i talk like the way i do i got
[__] with all the time especially
around other mexican people looking at
me like
because my nickname is widow growing up
white boy because i was this color my
whole life
and it didn't help that my step-dad's
now blue-eyed blonde hair
aryan
you know so going to school was weird he
would never get out with me
because he's covered in tattoos not on
his face and not on his hands
so he looked presentable
but i mean i met him axel rose playing
hacky sack my mom starts dating him goes
to prison i don't know the man i just
know hey my mom's new boyfriend is super
cool he's actually hanging out with me
like my dad
so i love the guy you know what i'm
saying i love that guy and we started
visiting him at a prison in prison for
he got like a three year
[Music]
one so i went there every weekend waking
up at four
going there and like i said last time i
was a little fat piece of [__] kid and
we were poor but i know if we went
to visit
ah there was these tri-tip sandwiches
and these vending machines and i was
like yeah
can i go you want to try this out
everything i know there's a single
plastic slide door
exactly
like some hospital tri-tip sandwiches
dude that's the [__] they had at ups
shout out to ups baltimore primary one
joe avenue that's the [__] the guy would
uh vending machine it was a big room but
that's
you get a cheese steak in there but
nasty [__] yeah never good stuff right
but it's in there and it rotates yeah
you gotta you pay it and you slide that
window open and get it that's exactly
what i did on your hands
of nickels
oh man so again
because i want to tell more stories of
course but again
your brown family is rolling in to
prison
yeah my sister's to visit a white
supremist yeah is it supremacist or
supremacist
[Music]
the grammar wasn't really on his mind
back then
but
i mean to me all i know is i'm going to
visit him how's that not a death
sentence for him in prison though okay
i never asked that question
when i got out he was uh
one of the better people i ever met i
know it sounds crazy but even to this
day he's one of the most upstanding
people i ever met
when it comes to
doing what you're gonna say if you say
you're gonna do he [__] did it when i
got out my best friend was black
and
his dad was the like the head cop of our
town just giant i think i mentioned this
last year yeah i mentioned this last
time and um
he explains it to me all the time that
he's racism belongs in jail outside he
gets to live his life
you know
that's what he says like he's not a
racist outside of he always told me like
it doesn't you have to do that
to live that's he always told me because
he went
to y.a at 14 prison 18 i see these
documentaries all the time and that's
what they tell you you're either coming
with us or you're or you're [__] dead
yeah it's it's almost at the point where
i can't ever talk about some of the
stuff he said but he's told me some
stories his first day in prison he just
sliced this guy's face up because he was
like hey uh uh what do i do i'm an 18
year old blonde kid and uh he called
chester but apparently it's like a child
molester so he's like he was a chester
so they told me like
go stab this fool in the face
so i mean he explained it to me when my
mom and him got divorced
but it's way more graphic i probably
it's just he explained a lot to me
but i get that feeling again like i just
feel like creepy how old were you when
he tells you this story i was 12. jesus
yeah because they were getting uh
separated he was like you're gonna be my
son no matter what
you know he was like my dad i almost
changed my last name to his my dad was
not around ever but i never saw him as
like oh you're a [__] racist
or you're a murderer or nothing like
that it was always oh it's my stepdad
because you met out of prison stuff yeah
i met him prison stepped up yeah and i'm
brown
my sister's brown as [__]
he has no problems with us my best
friend
is black he loves that [__] kid
i never got the vibe of anything
hateful ever
but in jail when he used to come out the
door for visiting
he'll always look different he always
had like a
i don't know how to explain he had like
a
dead stare until he got to us and then
he oh hey
and then it was always like
back to
scary [__] yeah that's that's scary yeah
but i don't know how
it was okay in there for him
i'm assuming
something to do with mexican people he
has to do something with them for that
to be allowed yeah because
it's not like i'm [__] making it up i
went there to corcoran every [__]
weekend
we walked the little cell
cement block thing
the sandwiches the one guard
at the door the one guard at the front
the guy that checks you in
same dudes every weekend
it's not fun
it's not like now that i think about it
was
four hours of waiting take everything
you have off uh
what's your name patent us down like it
was
it wasn't fun but like i was fat kid i
went for [__] sandwiches man i was
hungry and [__] all the time yeah like i
was a fat kid because every time there
was food i would smash on it because my
mom was not doing the best for us as a
kid and uh
yeah that's what i grew up into it was
weird the last time i ever saw him they
had been divorced 12 when i got was 12.
i saw when i was 18.
i was delivering pizza selling weed like
i talked about
and i saw a bunch of tweakers which is
normal but around a car like they're all
getting taught something
and i pull up to drop the pizza off
across the street and that's my [__]
step dad under a car teaching all these
tweakers how to [__] take a uh engine
out he was an engineer he's so [__]
smart man he's teaching these women yeah
they're all these guys are just looking
like that they're probably trying to
steal the catalytic converter [__]
honestly
this is the money you want to get it
from the muffler
all right
[__] unless you get it from the muffler
dude i swear now that i think about it
it's probably what the [__] he was doing
there's a bunch of white tweaker dude
just
and one lady you know one chick with him
at all times
and uh i just said his name
and he popped his head up
and he looked so [__] disappointed
because he was on one so bad like he you
could see his eyes were gone
but the one thing i noticed is all these
white tweaker dudes just stared at me
like they were gonna fight me and tell
him that's my son and then everybody
just like what the [__] yeah for real
kids you [__] son
this brown [__]
and that's the last time i ever saw him
man that was it
no i lied i saw him at college one day
because he went to school too but he had
no teeth he was all sucked up
so i kind of avoided him in school
it was weird going to school with my
stepdad that is weird how old was he
when he was going
44 45. so not far from my age
cracked out of his head and going to get
an education he had like six degrees in
prison because he's an engineer he's a
[__] genius but he has felonies he
never got to he couldn't get a job he's
trying to be the teacher out of our uc
when uc merced happened he's trying to
get a uc job as an engineer
and they're like yeah you're qual what
the [__] did you do
see it's arrests
yeah of course fighting how many cops
[__] damn there's the stories
for days with that guy but he's gone now
he's back in prison i saw it online and
that's it he's gone he's never coming
back man and it's sad as [__] because i
know how cool he is
but drugs drugs took him and that's it
but yeah that's how i grew up that guy
well tell me you got a list of stories
here so let's start with this toy chess
story the toy chest story i wanted to
talk about because i know you like let's
dig into your little life a little bit
more because after 16 i was doing
everything by myself and nobody you know
till now you know so
the toy chest stories takes place i was
in la my mom moved
okay
we walked into my mom's friend's house
and there was this tall
tim curry looking dude
and i remember my mom looks at him and
they look at each other and they just
stared at each other and i was like what
the [__] is this [__]
they fell in love or some [__]
two days later i moved to l.a with my
mom and this new dude my mom wasn't the
best
i like to think of her as like star from
lost boys like you got your kid in a
cave [__] what the [__] wrong with
you
go back to your mom's house
like she's a nice lady but you're not
making the best [__] decisions so we
move with this guy
i told the story last time uh about i
was gonna say that on the [__] floor
yeah same guy okay um so we moved there
i didn't know they were all twacked out
at the time because it's my mom it's
just she's mean that's all i know she's
[__] mean she's gonna beat your ass
don't say anything stupid and um
[Music]
do you ever have a bunk bed oh yeah hell
yeah did you sleep on top yeah for a
minute and then my brother complained
that i had to go to the bottom oh you
liked the top
yeah i liked it oh hell i roll off my i
roll in my sleep as a kid i'd always
move in my sleep you didn't have that
little ladder no no hell no
that little the little blocker no i put
yellows on the edge because i i
i'm known to throw up on the floor yeah
that's where you should put the pillow
yeah you're right you're right
um but i i'm known to do that i knew i
would fall asleep and fall off the bed
my sister's a dick so anyway i'm on the
top
and uh my mom doesn't pay attention to
us and i don't give a [__] i'm watching
street sharks and [__] i don't care i'm
six
so we moved to la
and i know they smoke cigs in their room
a lot so we're not allowed in their room
because my mom i have asthma [__]
dick and they're smoking in the house
they're smoking in the room but she's
like yo it's in the room so you can
never come in here but it was her excuse
to like yo we're smoking meth in here
don't [__] come in here i didn't know
but they were also smoking cigs because
they go hand in hand you know
and um i know not to knock on the door
after a certain time my mom would beat
the [__] out of you
don't ever [__] open the door
but i'm not saying like my mom was
always like hulking up on me but she
kind of was you know
and i remember man
i just woke up mid [__] air
like falling off the bed
and i just you know that weightlessness
you ever the first time you felt that
you're like oh the [__] is this
so i'm a kid i'm free falling
and i just feel that's why i still have
this huge bump right here or dip i hit
my head on remember those wood toy
chests with your bears and drums yeah
those ones with the lid
so i cracked my hand on the side on the
corner and all the [__] nights in the
middle of the night because i woke up to
just falling and then
and i just remember like stinging
searing ass
headache everywhere
but it's the middle of the night so the
[__] am i gonna do like get my ass
whooped or wrist that she cares enough
you know what i'm saying like i didn't
know what to do
sister's just as mean as my mom so
i like try to wake her up
your sister yeah she's only almost eight
i'm sick she tells me to [__] off
i hate europe you were a little kid she
tells me to [__] off shut the [__] up
that's what she tells me and i remember
i teared because i was more hurt by that
than i was like the blood that's gushing
out of the bag [__] i told her i can't
really move my head my head and i'm
trying to explain to her and she'll shut
the [__] up and then she turned and
where she turned and i just like oh
you [__] and our army crawled my ass to
my mom's i was hurt i was [__] up man
i crawled to the door opened my door i
remember all this [__]
i get my mom here's my door you walk out
my mom's door's right there it's a
[__] apartment
and i'm about to knock on my mom's door
from like from my hips i'm all [__]
i'm hurt
it's funny to laugh now
it is it's funny to me now and i went to
knock and i went
it's not [__] worth it i did knock
and i just fell
asleep i was there just sitting like
in the hallway just like trying to like
should i and i fell asleep trying to
decide but i woke up to my mom like what
the [__] in the morning
and i explained to her she's like why
are you in the live why are you in the
[__] hallway and i go so i fell look
at this and she's like what the [__]
wrong with you i had a big dip and it
was cut
and i explained to her like i didn't
want to knock because you're gonna
[__] beat the [__] out of me right
but i didn't say beat the [__] i'm like
well you're gonna hit me
i know the rule and she just started
tearing and then we moved like two days
later then she stopped doing drugs that
was it no yeah
she like felt
so shitty that she was whoa that clean
that made her go clean that and she said
she saw herself in the mirror and she
was like a demon
all [__] twacked out in the in the
bathroom
and then she's and then this happened
and then we moved back
that was it if you dread looking at your
credit card statements you are not alone
the weight of debt can be crippling but
upstart can help you on your path to
financial freedom upstart is the fast
and easy way to pay off your debt with a
personal loan all online so whether
you're paying off credit cards whether
you're consolidating high interest debt
or you're funding personal expenses over
a million people have used upstart to
get one fixed monthly payment with a
clear payoff date rather than looking at
credit score alone upstart considers
other factors like your income your
current employment and your credit
history to find you a smarter rate for
your loan you can check your rate
without impacting your credit score in
minutes for loans between 1 000 all the
way up to 50 000 and you can even
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan find out
how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com honeydew that's upstart.com
honeydew don't forget to use my url to
let them know i sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application
upstart.com
honeydew there's nothing wrong with
taking care of your skin people who
think skincare is exclusively for women
man you're dead wrong i know from a kid
i had acne i had everything going on i
was always trying to take care of my
skin and
you know it doesn't always happen great
you know what i'm saying but what i got
left i like and i want to keep it going
disco is a clean skincare brand based in
austin texas all disco products are
created specifically for male skin
issues like under eye bags dark circles
acne razor burn oily skin dry skin and
wrinkles disco products are easy to use
effective and affordable and they take
the guesswork out of taking care of your
skin right now i'm using the under eye
roller i'm using the face scrub and then
there's this charcoal face scrub i use
in the shower that i really love that
i've never had before their disco
repairing eye stick is formulated with
caffeine
that's fancy y'all peptides and moisture
to transform those under eye bags after
a long night of partying gaming working
or whatever your vice may be and if you
want to check out this go and try their
incredible skincare products for
yourself i got a special offer for my
honeydew audience go to
letsdisco.com honeydew or enter honeydew
at checkout for 30 off your first order
that's a lot guys 30 off that's let's
letsdisco.com
honeydew for 30 off your first order
thank you disco if the pandemic taught
us anything it's that connection to the
people we love most is what really
matters not the kind of connection that
comes from a curated social feed or
chaotic group text but the everyday
moments where life really happens aura
smart frames bring those moments to the
forefront of daily life making it easy
to share photos and now video two and
feel closer from anywhere in the world
it's beautifully designed it's easy to
set up and it's one of oprah's favorite
things for 2021 three years running now
and our frame is the perfect holiday
gift each frame comes in a beautiful
gift box there's no wrapping required
and once your person sets it up which
takes no more than two minutes and turns
on the frame they'll immediately see
cherished memories and their favorite
faces you can even personalize it by
pre-loading photos for a surprise that
will have them crying tears of joy which
i think is really cool you can do a
surprise party maybe you're getting a
puppy for the kids i don't know but you
can pre-load it and set it up i got one
it's cool i love it you just sit over
there and you know no more old-school
photo albums now the pictures just flow
by over there you can look over and be
like oh look at that i remember when we
did that take advantage of ours best
deals of the year with black friday
cyber monday pricing now through
november 30th visit
auraframes.com now to get gifting that's
a a-u-r-a-frames.com
listeners use my code honeydew and
you'll get thirty dollars off ara's
best-selling digital picture frames now
let's get back to the duke damn robert
he was i remember the day we moved out
my mom used to beat the [__] out of that
guy wait your mom beat him he was a
[__]
like you can't say things to my mom
without like what'd you say what did you
see what are you doing she just pokes
him grabbing by the [__] shirt type
[__]
yeah i thought you said she was little
though she is she like she's still
grabbing by the shirt like a little tabs
yeah he's he was like
six two-ish six three
my mom was like five five
times i should beat the [__] out of
people and uh
that was it man i just remember thinking
uh i don't give a [__]
let's move back she took us to
mcdonald's and right off the bat i'm
like why the [__] we have mcdonald's
we're poor as [__]
like i know we can't do this and then
she's like well i think we're gonna move
back she was trying to like break it to
us and we're moving so was he freaking
out that you were leaving they didn't
know yet my mom was mid-pack
at midnight
oh no he goes what the [__] she'll get
the [__] out of here and then
he just left the apartment and then they
broke up he was so afraid to stop her
that we just moved and that's what made
her go clean wow she stopped doing drugs
yeah man it's wild to think about
what a [__]
but also what if you knocked that night
does your mom continue to use probably
yeah probably beats my ass too though
so i wasn't trying to get my ass whooped
on top of
not being able to i was an insomnia i
still am
so uh
she used to beat the [__] out of me if i
didn't go to sleep
but i remember crying it would make me
fall asleep
like the burning of your you know what
i'm saying like getting my ass whooped
and
stare in the [__] corner that's what
she used to tell me stare at the corner
and then close the door and i just stare
there until six in the morning i could i
wasn't can't sleep
but um did her behavior toward the
that
well that specific behavior did it
change after she went oh she's gonna
dick
so it wasn't the drugs
no she's an [__]
my mom's a [__] [__] dude
if anything she got worse
really
more more strict
yeah but my sister caught the worst of
it because my sister's an [__] like
her so they butt heads and she'd beat
the [__] out of my sister
and then she'd put her in the room with
me because we're living in a [__]
little apartment and then my sister beat
the [__] out of me yeah of course
because i didn't get beat up right yeah
i was constantly getting my ass what man
either my mom or my [__] sister um
tell me about the drug deal gone wrong i
want to hear about this
all right drug deal gone wrong man uh
there's about seven but this one is the
one
still pisses me off
mainly because
the friend i had i'm no longer friends
with he's a piece of [__]
this wasn't the reason why i'm not
friends with him either and you're gonna
say how did that not stop it
the friendship wasn't over then and if
no it wasn't
i just sell a lot of weed a box means uh
damn do you talk can i say this on your
show i could talk about this [__] a box
a box means 100 pounds can i talk i can
say this though sure i mean joey diaz
talks about what he talks about okay so
a box means 100 pounds so it's just like
a slang term of growers like oh i need a
box all right so at what eleven hundred
what oh geez cool bring me a hundred
thousand dollars a hundred eleven
thousand dollars
you know because you know over
a thousand eleven hundred dollars a
pound a hundred pounds
[__] adds up man but you never make
that money it's always i made fifty
dollars per pound
i made some money today it's you know
it's fun to me
selling me was uh started off just to
smoke for free well how did you get into
it
i just got a ten sack from this kid at
school
and then this girl brittany asked me do
you know where i can get weed
and in my head i'm thinking
tell her you sell weed just [__] try
it i don't know why i was in the i
remember what bench at high school
and i sold her half of it i was like
yeah i'll be right back i went to the
bathroom just
broke off half the weed that i just got
and sold her for ten dollars so you just
made your money i made my money back and
she's like oh my god [__] yeah and she
walked away oh [__]
and i was poor i didn't get lunch ticket
i was the kid with lunch tickets but my
mom didn't show up so i didn't get the
[__] lunch ticket sometimes
we didn't have oh we have fire we did
not yeah and then some other kid asked
me for weed about 15 minutes later
because he heard that she got weed for
me probably not good that she told
everybody right away but i sold the rest
of it for 15 bucks
so for 10 i made 25
my friend joe comes up and i show him
the money i go you think i'm lying you
think i have 25 dollars somewhere i'm
[__] poor
and he goes all right we need to buy an
ounce of weed like oh let's [__] do
it and we s all the money i could
possibly follow
for 15. just turn 15. because uh i'm a
year behind so i just turned 15 i'm in
10th grade
and um
about an ounce of weed and we started
stashing it all around school
on sundays so mondays like what do you
need okay i'll be back so certain drain
pipes like that's fives that's tens
that's 20s you'd put them in you'd leave
it at the school yeah because uh if
someone's snitching on me they're gonna
find it on me so i thought
it was always my mom's gonna [__]
kill me that was my always my thing like
if i'm gonna do something i'm not gonna
get caught doing it so there was the
wood pile for wood shop and never moved
for 30 years
so we would know take three steps put
your arm there's a [__] half ounce
three steps and there's another half
ounce in sacks so that's how me and joe
did it yeah i love the criminal mind i
love it it's just a
separation
i can't get caught with it because i'll
die
and um it doesn't rain emer said unless
it's winter so the drain pipes are not
[__] working they're dry so i would
just shove certain
sacks in certain drain pipes so
i could just walk pretend time i should
grab it and go make [__] money at
lunch time
and we sold an ounce our first lunch and
that's when i got the whole ounce the
whole [__] ounce and everybody only
had five and ten dollars and we sold all
of this [__]
and i'm poor and i'm sitting here
looking at 40 profit with joe going holy
[__]
i crush cans man like this is [__]
awesome and you know you grow poor
40 bucks is every [__] thing in the
world when you're in high school
i remember i used to have to drive the
atms where i could take out five dollars
um you know what i mean most of them
were 20. i had to go to that
neighborhood over there
to get my fives and my tens or richard
pryor said the twos and fuse you know
what i mean like i don't have enough to
get 20. could i get five on this 17 i
got left we just finally got one of
those in our town so i didn't know about
that ex i didn't know that exit i didn't
have a card till i was 20 [__] three
but
i fell in love with solo weed as soon as
i realized and i just smoked weed i
smoked all that 40 extra so here's what
i wanted to ask you about because it's
interesting to me you think like you see
this drug dealer out there you think
this guy
or girl whatever knows what the [__]
they're doing you know but it's like any
other job you start off with growing
pains and [__] up so
tell me
some of the mistakes you made early on
uh in in the learning process of how to
sell weed
don't all right
your friends are your friends but stop
[__] hooking up your friends i would
lose money selling weed to my friends
come on man i'm your friend
and this is what you're going to give me
for 20 oh you bastard and i just feel
they're my friends that's the only thing
i ever [__] up i was just always too
nice i've fronted people ounces
for years
an ounce come back pay me for the ounce
and can i can i front me another one
like
i'm just applying you're all right [__]
but
i was such a nice i'm just too nice i
wish i was a [__] [__] i would
have made more money but
like i've said before there's like 30
fathers out there that owe me money
right now because they never came back
and i know they all grew up and had kids
and moved
i remember everybody's name and i
remember every [__] dollar that they
owe me
and when i see them go hey remember in
like ninth grade you owe me 15 [__]
dollars sir is that your kid nice to
meet you you owe me 15
i'm not gonna really ask it but i
remember it all so that's the only thing
i ever [__] up on is being too nice
and never front anybody anything
that's the only thing i [__] up on is
losing money
trusting people that they're as nice as
i am that's it but never any deal's gone
wrong or nothing like so sorry i'm off
track the deal gone wrong
100 packs the um
i'm about 21
and i have i buy like 10 pounds every
four days for myself so between
between the age of 15 and 21 you've
you've gone from an ounce at one lunch
to 100 pounds well i'm not it's not for
100 for me it's my friend needs it and i
go okay but you're still dealing with
this yeah like all right here i'll meet
you there bring the money cool thank you
my points ah [__] yeah like the box is
what every kid wants every trafficking
in the world wants a dollar on a box
that's ten thousand dollars of every
move that's a lot of [__] money when
you grow up poor [__] that's a lot of
money period yes but the risk is
what's california's not as bad but
anyway box my friend my good friend at
the time tells me hey i'm with my
so-and-so he needs a hundred or he says
a box and he tells me he's at 11 and i'm
gonna get him at eight so i was like did
i just make thirty thousand dollars
[__] yex making 300 bucks a pack
and he tells me uh
i'm looking at the money because i i
know this [__] i'm like are you sure
you need this if i call my friend that
has this he's gonna have to drive down
from santa cruz to sacramento or from
humble to sacramento
make sure this is real because i'm gonna
look like an [__] and my friend i
call him piece of [__] piece of [__]
friend says i'm looking at the money
just bring it
i call my friend he has to drive halfway
to humble to meet somebody because they
started driving gave him the box
it's not in a box but in huge duffel
bags and i meet him in sacramento and
i'm standing there with piece of [__]
friend and his
gigantic [__]
grower friend that needs this weed i'm
in a warehouse
there's a bunch of shitty doors and i'm
thinking like [__] man i know you well
but i don't like this and you carry at
the time no no no nothing a knife
nothing screwdriver you're gonna steal
it from me i'm not gonna fight you over
money i'll get it back
that's how i always thought i hear you
uh you win this round today
well i'll be back tomorrow so um
my friend gets there from humble
with the hundred i'm holding 25 in each
stuff well he has 25 25 4
duffels i carry two in he carries two in
piece of [__] friend is standing there
and i go so check him out
and his big friend goes what the [__] is
this
and i just like everything inside just
breaks i drove four hours for this
it's half my [__] day
my reputation with my friend is now on
the line i tell him oh he tells me he's
looking at the money let's go because he
that's all he wants to hear
thanks man he sold 100 pounds for me
[__] yeah you appreciate you
a big friend looks at me and goes i
don't want this
and i look at piece of [__] friend
and i'm trying to kill him with my eyes
like i'm gonna [__] stab the [__] not
for real like i'm gonna punch you
and i go you don't want the hundred
pounds and he goes dude i wanted to
check out a sample i don't even have the
money on me so my friend just straight
up [__] lied to me he obviously was
trying to put money on it and make his
money
he was trying to force this deal sample
and you all drove up
trying to find out giant friend is a
[__] industrial sized grower he just
needed a box because his [__] was drying
he goes that's 200 too high like i'm
good
so now i'm like
now you got to drive back not even that
i have my friend that drove i haven't
looked at him in the eyes yet because
he's standing next to me i'm just like
i'm sorry i'm sorry because he told me
like my wife thinks i'm at the store
my kids are having dinner
that's what he told me like this has to
be fast like oh dude he says he's
looking at the money just come he drove
two [__] hours
during dinner time yeah so as this
happens he tells me
i go i thought you said you're looking
at the money he goes i don't know what
you're talking about why would i say
that so i'm looking at my friend going
you're lying into my my face in front of
people to make me look stupid
i'm gonna [__] punch the [__] out of
you the guy goes yeah bro uh these are
too high like i'm sorry you drove
so i pick up these [__] pounds
and i start leaving to load them back
into my friend's car oh yeah and he goes
dude you know i'm mad right i know
you're mad i'm very [__] sorry what
can i do you have to restock because
some growers will do a restock fee
and it'd be
forty dollars a pound like that's four
thousand dollars
i'm about to lose when i thought i was
making 30.
you know it hurts and my friend says i
have to go to dinner you're driving
these back to my spot
and i look at piece of [__] friend and i
go i'm in a rental a red rental with
texas plates about to drive over the 17
pacheco pass a seventh the potential to
seventeen
drug highway in a rental car
and uh i wanted to kill my homie and i
drove with a hundred pounds on the
[__] freeway
oh my god how far how long it was like
two hours
but now i'm like in a red rental that's
the biggest
don't ever [__] carry weed in a
rental car
without estate plates you look like
you're [__] selling weed
so you know rosie and i just
i had power smoked joints i was so
nervous
and i went
dropped off the weed
and i made no money wasting my whole
[__] day and just gave myself a heart
attack that was the worst [__] drug
deal i ever [__] was part of
it really pissed me off yeah but uh yeah
i'm not friends with that guy anymore so
[__] that guy
and that's it man that was the worst
drug deal the worst drug i ever had go
wrong
i thought i made thirty thousand dollars
in five minutes and i didn't i was
pissed it hurt me so bad and i was at
the time when my other dealer went
missing so i was hurting like i couldn't
i hadn't had no weed connects besides
the guy that only sells 100 or boxes
like 10 pounds he's not going to give me
10.
[__] you basically but in a nice way
[__] you
so that was the worst that was the worst
what about turning down 10 million
dollars
okay
so the more i think about this
the more i feel like
yo you're on to something right so push
trees my clothing company i've started
in 2013.
i never talk about who the company is
they're a very [__] large clothing
company
holy [__] piece of [__] friend is in
this video is in this story okay piece
of [__] friend knows the owners of this
company and they are
40 50 mil a year clothing streetwear
brand
and i'm it's 2015. i'm a little
living in my par 600 house trying to
make my rent still because once i
stopped selling weed
i started doing instagram i stopped
selling weeks i was like i'm gonna get
my door kicked in
but also it's like lose eight thousand
dollars ish a month with weed
or make videos i really like and i just
fell in love with making videos and
now here we are so what age do you stop
selling weed then 22. okay so from 15 to
22 you went hard seven years like very
hard yeah yeah obviously nothing to show
for it i spent all of it and then
this instagram stuff hits and you decide
yeah i need to back off i mean merced
i'm gonna get my door kicked in or shot
because somebody's gonna say yo he's got
that that's what i mean seven years is a
long time to be in the drug game i feel
like and never
any kind of attempts on your life or
anything like that
i sold weed to my friends that was it
man yeah because when i say i was
selling 10 pounds every like four or
five days that's because some of my
friends sell weed too like oh here's a
quarter all right here's your quarter
pounder and there's reason
give it back to me all right cool all
right you want a half all right you want
a full pound [__] yes i'll get 11 pounds
now
that's how it worked out for me
but um
i'm sorry i got off topic which
well i was asking if you'd ever had any
attempts on your life or anything like
that but this was passing up on the 10
million sorry yeah the 10 million and um
it's clothing company piece of [__]
friend i'm at his house
i don't take him serious he's a goof
he's my friend though he's he's uh like
20 almost 30 years older than me though
so he's an older dude okay but he's an
established [__] he knows what
he's doing but he did that [__] with
me with a weed yeah and i'm looking at
this grown man like i'm gonna [__]
hit you
you know i'm here i am 21 years old i'm
gonna beat your ass you 45 year old man
like i'm gonna [__] you up
that's why i felt so like
you're grown don't do this thing so he
knows those owners i'm at his house
i am just on my phone probably hitting
comments or something and my friend just
like this walks into the front door
because he was taking a phone call and
he goes hey
how would you sell push trees for
just like that i'm only two and three
years into this
and i always said no i'll make 100 mil
i'm never gonna sell i always say like
it's gonna be worth mtv
one day i got that's how i always feel i
still do
and he walks in how much you sell just
like this
so the person can still hear me he just
does this [__] how much you still push
trees for
no nope
and he goes
so he says the company's all
is on the phone how much no no he said
it's my friend i told you about that's
what he said because he didn't tell me
the company all right like whatever with
this yeah like i don't know that
person's name he says it's on the phone
like how much would you sell
and uh
i say nothing
he goes [__] idiot he walks out the
door
30 seconds comes back in he goes would
you sell for 10 mil right now
and i go
nope
just like that i'm broke as [__]
i go nope
and he goes
would you sell for 10 million i go tell
him to suck my dude
that's what i said like just being a
cocky [__] but i said like i
accentuated dick hella longer than i
should have a [__] guy hears this
this [__] millionaire here's this kid
just tell him to suck my dick my
friend's eyes go
and he walks right out the room comes
back in three minutes later starts going
like just yelling at me like what the
[__] would you say that for you know
what kind of relationship i have with
these people i go who's on the phone who
the [__] is and i said this name like i
don't know who that is
he goes that was the owner and he says
the name and go no [__] wasn't
i going you tell me ten million dollars
reel right now goes thomas you just
[__] that up for yourself and i looked
at him and go who the [__] says that
[__] like this yeah peeking in the door
[__] you and it took me 35 minutes of
going are you serious until i believed
him because i know he knows these guys
and i [__] turned i would have took
it but i think you wouldn't have thing
and even no no because i know what it
would be so you didn't [__] it up then
no but but you [__] up if they came at
me and goes so here's a check i would
have been like thank you bro i know i
would have
i know i would have
but i say i don't but if it was in front
of me and the guy showed up i mean the
guy lives 40 minutes from where we were
at
if i knew it was real i would have
considered it more
and kept ten percent of royalties
but yeah i totally suck my dick and then
it went a bunch of [__] happened and
they started going hard on me that exact
company
so i've had a big online feud with these
guys for [__] seven years now because
of this quit hanging out with that
friend
it's been five years i don't chill with
him okay good [__] that guy
he [__] me out of a bunch of money
it sounds like it but no the reason why
i'm not friends with him anymore a third
time he [__] me out of a lot of money
and uh
it's just annoying it's annoying the guy
that uh own zig zag i'm on the phone
with this guy's a billionaire i'm on the
phone with him in front of my 600 a
month house and merced in my [__] car
i'm like come on remember in forrest
gump we're sitting next to a millionaire
that's how i felt like i'm on the phone
with a billionaire and then they cut me
out of the contract uh two weeks later
my friend went around me to keep my
shares
and then the guy uh stole the company
from him so now the guy that owns zigzag
owns everything there you go
so there it is
that's that's the other time he [__]
me using the internet without expressvpn
is like leaving your keys in your car
while you're running to the gas station
for a snack most of the time you're
probably fine but what if you come back
to see someone driving off with your car
every time you connect to an unencrypted
network in cafes hotels airports any
hacker on the same network can gain
access to your personal data your
passwords your financial details all
that stuff guys so it's easy to use fire
up the app and click one button to get
protected it works on all your devices
your phones your laptops your tablets
and more so you can stay secure on the
go look i love it i use it i'm traveling
all the time right now i'm constantly in
different hotels airplanes everywhere
and i'm definitely not leaving my stuff
unprotected i love that i'm out there
going wherever i need to go and all my
personal information is protected so
secure your online data today by
visiting expressvpn.com
honeydew that's e-x-p-r-e
honeydew and you can get an extra three
months free
expressvpn.com honeydew ho ho ho
gentlemen the holidays came early here
and manscape the leading men's hygiene
brand manscape just launched new
products including their all new ultra
premium body wash and a two-in-one
shampoo and conditioner it's time to
give yourself or someone who needs it
the gift of beautiful skin hair and
balls this holiday season go to
manscape.com and use code honeydew for
20 off and free shipping untrim pubes
are a thing of the past and it's
possible you have santa's beer in your
pants i tell you all the time man i used
to use those old trimmers razors i'm
down there giving myself nicks uh
ingrown hairs it's unsightly man this
thing just trims it up doesn't nick you
there's no bloodbath in my underwear
nothing all right inside the performance
package 4.0 you'll find a signature
lawnmower 4.0 this electric trimmer has
proprietary advanced skin safe
technology to reduce cuts on your nuts
it's also waterproof so you can use it
in the shower it's like a gift to your
partner with less mess and every guy out
there needs to add manscape to their
wish list this season get 20 off and
free shipping with the code honeydew at
manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping at manscape.com when you use
the code honeydew clean up your nuts and
make santa proud this year now let's get
back to the do
um tell me about the edible blackout
you ready
i talked about this one last year
i
i smoke a lot of weed i ate a lot of
edibles i do challenges on my other
channel
i can handle weed
i blacked out so [__] hard
off this edible
i was running a push tree's booth so i'm
talking to people taking the money
taking pictures with people that follow
our stuff
searching through bins on organized as
[__] at a booth at a cannabis festival
i'm late i'm driving from merced to la
i leave i i hate being like i was three
minutes late today i was pissed i
[__] hate being late
i didn't need anything i get gas get
back and go i don't want to be late to
my own booth and people are waiting
there to buy clothes and i'm not there
that's [__] unprofessional
so i get there and the guy next to me my
friend he hired a chef he's making
medicated sliders but they're putting a
concentrate hash
in the sauce and then drought putting it
over the sliders okay so that's what's
medicated but he doesn't know
how much is going into these things
i walk up one of my friends is looking
at me oh i mean [__] gone
and he warns me don't eat him he warned
me you don't need him yeah he's [__]
losing it and telling you yeah
yeah he and he's he's a big smoker and
i'm looking at him and i even told him i
hear a [__]
man up like you are right you know where
you're at like you're at a weed festival
be okay
i i was just being a dick
i ate three of those things because i
was hungry because i didn't eat oh my
god it's medicated it's fine but then
this other company i know brings me a
plate of rice krispies and brownies all
medicated [__] and my friend makes
medicated chicken wings at the time so
i'm eating those and he makes medicated
lemonade so i'm chugging he's everything
medicaid yeah but i'm starving right
yeah and then the people that make the
brownies make medicated empanadas so i'm
sitting here i probably ate like four of
everything and i ate about five of those
sliders
two hours in like i said i've smoked my
fair share of weed
two hours plus you're smoking weed yeah
oh for sure
all that stuff but that's like that's
water like i'm just chilling the edibles
is
i didn't know i'm sitting on my chair
and all my hearing goes away
and i hear
real loud
and i'm in a crowd of people
and they're all waiting in line to buy
[__] from me the guy they follow and i'm
just sitting here
i can't hear anything and i start like
oh [__] i'm gonna throw up oh my god i'm
gonna die
i don't know what to do and then i'm
looking across at a booth and everything
gets blurry
but the one thing i'm looking at tunnel
vision i've never had that before
so i'm looking at rosie because she ate
everything i ate
like were she okay she wasn't okay she
was having the same panic but she didn't
want to tell me and i didn't want to
tell her that's what happens i didn't
know but we're running a booth taking
pictures i don't remember any of the
pictures
on top of this
i really had to go the bathroom but at a
cannabis event
people are high and
if you've been to one dudes piss
everywhere there's piss everywhere i go
to the bathroom there's piss everywhere
i can't take my i have to take a [__]
i can't take my pants down they're
getting covered in piss yeah
but i also can't hover there because
this everything's covered in piss so i
go to the bathroom and go nah
i'm backing out remember i'm paranoid
too high the whole time and you know
people are stopping me on the way to the
bathroom to take pictures and [__] i've
never been paranoid hide had to take a
[__] i've never been in that oh this
gets so much worse this is our
hour too it's a 12-hour event man
like i'm there all day right
i go back
i'm in the booth just trying to hold
together and this is where everything
goes [__] really bad
the booth next to us uh there's no wall
it's just [__] canopies
somebody put a bag of weed like a huge
duffel bag because they're selling weed
there and everything
i'm just talking to somebody i'm [__]
up i back up trip over the bag and
there's a woman sitting in a chair i
land on her flatten her the [__] out
bad like all my fat body weight slams
this lady she wasn't little she was a
big lady but i still
knocked her out the chair she's flat
and i'm doing the whole
i'm so sorry trying to get up and not
trying to tell everybody that oh i'm
spinning i'm gonna throw up i'm too
[__] up
and uh she's like oh it's okay it's okay
i'm like i'm so sorry the bag's there
and she's like it's oh it's fine it's
fine
hour later i tried to take another
attempt to the bathroom
and i go and i get i have my pants down
and i'm like ah and i leave no i have to
take a [__] so bad but i also don't want
piss all over me people going to take
pictures of me they'll have to piss his
pants wow
huh like i don't want that on social
media about me right
i go back
everything's going fine i stopped eating
everything
it's three hours later
i just get i don't know what happens man
i just got dizzy i [__] like passed
out fainted
i just got dizzy started seeing this
yeah i started stepping
hit like
elbow and i grabbed her whole shoulder
to stop my fall
rude as [__] but i'm over here blacking
out but she doesn't know that right yeah
she just like oh that's the guy from the
internet that smokes pounds right oh
yeah i'm sure he's [__] up
so she just thinks i'm being rude at
this point she's like oh it's okay
not as nice this time like oh it's fine
the first time she's like oh my god are
you all right now she's like
yeah okay
it's fine
two more hours they should go by go back
to the bathroom to try for this i'm like
hour six nights yeah let's say you're
holding it for five or six hours i'm
holding it and i'm a king of that i've
been i
the bathrooms are gross
i go and this time remember when
hoverboards were around and everybody
was riding the little
so i'm looking under stalls like which
one's open i'm gonna i'll take the piss
i'm gonna [__] my pants
and i just see
feet and a hoverboard in the stall and i
hear a guy oh
the guy's pissing on the hoverboard no
and i'm imagining yo this guy's trying
to hold his dick not fall that's
hilarious i just start busting the [__]
up laughing dying laughing stomach
doesn't hurt as much anymore the guy
backs out full force backwards bam and
he's just doing this
and i just go oh my god i start telling
him how [__] funny i think it is
and he's not amused at all he's like
goes past me and goes
you're that yolo guy i like your videos
oh thanks man
i'm like are you gonna say that after
you're like yeah
real funny i thought it was hilarious
right
i go in and i
spark hits me i roll my pants and i
finally got to go to the bathroom after
like hour six so i come out less
stressed
it's not over
i don't know what happened we're
cleaning up i don't know what the [__]
happened right
the booth next to us is uh i know the
company but the owner's not there
he has all his workers there so i never
saw him that day so this is important
part
i'm packing up i'm packing up all my
bins
i'm packing up all my bins everybody's
stuff next to me is in my booth which
kind of pissed me off because i'm trying
not to fall i'm [__] up i don't want
it to happen again i can see the lady
standing talking
she's not she doesn't like me yeah she
doesn't like me
i'm packing all my stuff up
and i don't know what happened i'm
walking with bins two big stacked bins
and i just
catch someone's [__] bag man
i [__] full force into this lady's
leg the same lady the same [__] woman
three separate times in one day
rosie
is there to see all of this
and she knows how bad i feel but the
third time she goes hard on me
i like trip and it's almost on purpose
it's like i'm targeting for sure for
sure but she's like over here standing
now three different locations three
different spots man twice while she was
sitting last time she was standing
she starts yelling at me calling me a
piece of [__] you [__] like on
like she's saying everything she should
because in her eyes i'm a piece of [__]
in my eyes i can't [__] believe this
[__] no way this is seinfeld [__] to
me it's kirby enthusiasm
yep get all my stuff to the car i'm with
rosie i'm looking to hat her and she'll
she [__] hates you i go i let's get
the [__] out of here okay and the
event's over so everybody's packing up
so she was just standing around with her
booth she's next door
and i'm pulling my hair i just smacked
her with my bins my [__] bins of
clothes
that's how i feel i'm putting all my
stuff away
packing up the guy that uh owns the
booth next to me the owner that i
recognize he's walking the parking lot
hey what's up sorry man like you know i
have a regular job and [__] so i
couldn't make it today but i had
everybody working for me well yeah man
you were actually right next to me he's
like oh [__]
i'll be right back let me get you some
[__] it's a weed company i go all right
cool i'll be right back
i'm packing all my stuff up he comes
back who the [__] did he come back with
her who's his wife that i never met no
it's his
wife as she's walking up i can see her
and i go oh
my [__] god and rosie's right here
she goes oh my [__] god as he's
walking up i see her just
and he goes this is my friend thomas i
was telling you about she's just like
i'll tell you about what the [__]
happened later she goes oh nice to meet
you she shook my hand and just walked
the [__] away he even looked at me like
all right yeah here's that stuff man
i'll see you i never seen that guy again
never talked to him again i haven't seen
but i blacked out i don't remember most
of it i almost [__] my pants three two
four four times i remember there was
about 30 pictures that day i don't
remember any of them i was going in and
out i put a mind array it was gone i've
never been that [__] high in my life
yeah she hates me um sorry tell me about
airport smuggling
i'm a [__] idiot
um you watch blow yeah i'm very i grew
up on movies my mom was
not watching me so i would say like the
cable guy but not creepy like sit down
and watch this so i was watching though
like i always say like reservoir dogs
good fellas i always talk about like the
old movies
kramer vs kramer as a kid like i was a
little boy watching this [__] trying to
understand
so i watched blow and i'm very
influenced by movies as a kid i was
about 13 and when johnny depp is walking
with the white coat and ram jams playing
and he has the coke and the false bottom
i he was the coolest person on the
planet to me and i thought it was the
coolest thing
[__] ever and i love ram jam as as it
is
and uh i started selling weed my dad
moves to oregon he gets clean my dad
gets clean when i'm like 13 or 14. what
made him get clean a [__]
intervention at my grandma's it was
really and it worked you you were there
yeah it was weird i went to my dad's a
his uh
drug anonymous meetings he was trying
for a while but
us going hey stop that [__] as a family
was weird as [__] and he just said all
right i'll move to oregon because my
uncle was really rich he has a
moving company he's making maybe one to
two mil a year off a moving company and
he's gonna pay my dad absurd amount to
to help him somebody's like all right
come get clean work with me we'll get
[__] rich together
scenery change so my dad went to
portland i'm going to visit my dad for
the first time and i'm not going
weedless
so i sell weed at the time
i figure you know it's only a flight
i've seen
johnny depp do this [__]
and blow i'm gonna [__] go for it and
you're how old 14.
yeah so uh you're going to no 15 50. you
decided 10th grade i'm gonna fly with
weed on a plane
that'll have no weed
i took the chance i duct taped the [__]
out of it you know the number one thing
they look for is it
i mean wouldn't you okay yeah yeah
suitcases this [__] was all duct taped
up like we're gonna have to cut that up
all right i didn't think about that
you're completely [__] right
airport security don't give a [__] at
sacramento i guess i duct taped it i had
my american beauty double uh vhs
remember the double too long of movies
had to be on two tapes so i had took the
tapes out put the sack of weed in there
put a sock
over the weed for to try to help it i
put in ziploc bags then the sock in the
case
put it in my clothes
i'm going to the airport
and they do the random search [__] to me
they pull you to the side
and she doesn't get to the thing she
doesn't get to the uh
to the movies the movie box and i'm
sitting thinking can i run
like from a [__] airport no you can't
my aunt's dropping me off
and i was a 4.0 student at the time
so everyone's like
not expecting me to get caught trying to
smuggle [__] weed right so my aunt's
there and i'm like ah i'm gonna throw
the [__] up where can i run this is a
big empty space there's nowhere i made
it through
almost [__] my [__] pants they didn't
catch it no they didn't catch it almost
[__] my pants right
i did this like five or six times right
i've almost got caught three times that
was the first time they opened my bag
the way back i'm going back to
california
and i bring weed
i don't know what i you know what it was
i wanted my friends be like yo you
brought a zip of oregon but yeah from
this guy billy i work with my uncle
hired this guy he found i smoke weed and
he sold my little ass as an ounce of
wheat now that i know he ripped me the
[__] off but yeah he sold me some weed i
did the same thing but my dad's now
dropping me out my sober dad's now
dropping me off
at the airport he's all proud and shay's
like hey you're on the [__] football
team you're starting yeah i'm selling
weed but he doesn't know that
he's dropped me off my dad's like
ah man it's good to see him like wow my
dad's sober and he's here i'm going to
jail because i have this weed they do
the random search [__] again again
on the way back
and uh the guy searches all my [__] he's
going through everything and i'm sitting
there ah
you know
the ducks like trying to say something
about oregon right yeah yeah and my
dad's like
yeah you know football he just thinks
i'm having a conversation with this dude
and they're going through all my [__] i
know the weeds under my blue checkered
shirt
i know it is it's in the same thing it's
in the same box i mean i'm bringing it
back
and she's the dude's going through
everything everything everything and as
he's going to like two shirts before the
blue shirt i look at my dad like
slow-mo i'm about to tell you what's
about to happen because i didn't want
him to be like [__] i'm like dada you
should probably step aside i'm gonna get
arrested you tell him no i'm about to
like
so
i'm gonna break your image of me real
quick you know i'm a [__] good kid on
the team
and the guy gets to the blue shirt and
goes all right good closes it and i all
the [__] that was coming out of my body
came back in i was about to [__] my
pants like like groundhog day [__] i
thought i was gonna [__] my pants
this is my dad
he's looking at me all happy the first
time in life he's there i'm about to go
to jail in front of him and i didn't
and i've been doing it ever since but
now what i do is i call the airline the
day before i tell him hey i'm gonna have
two to three ounces of weed on me
can you not touch it
and they and i go can you forward me to
your police state a police department of
the airport no yeah i print out my rec
or my id
with my ids faxed like a copied on it
and a very nice note
and i tape it and i tape i put the weed
in my mason jars and i duct tape the
whole top the whole thing because i know
fools will open it taking some nugs out
[__] that
and i tape uh put my wheat on top now my
two pieces of paper and it says don't
touch my [__] but nicely
if you touch my [__] get me off the
[__] plane don't touch my [__] but
very polite i've never been [__] with
ever in life and and that product's
never been [__] up every flight every
flight i do it's all this day every
single time
i'm not saying do it and i always make
sure i'm not going to like idaho or
something yeah i'm going to at least a
somewhat legal recreational state right
another state yeah but that's what i do
now because
i'm an adult bro go take me to jail you
don't take me joe for weed i'll be out
today
but as a kid i'm gonna die i'm gonna
[__] my pants my life's over so that's
airport smuggling yeah that's [__]
stupid i don't know why i did that [__]
um
tell me about your first car buying your
first car
first cars in oregon too in portland you
ever been to portland yeah oh yeah you
know 182nd street or 82nd street it's
like seven miles of car dealerships yeah
that's where it was
so my dad's working up there i've been
doing moving so i was about 13
just you know doing moving jobs with my
dad and my uncle
and
i want to buy a car man i'm i've my
whole life is i'm trying to get money
because i'm poor
so
this is right when i just started
selling weed
so
i don't know it's about a month or two
before i start selling wheat sorry i go
up there i work for a couple weeks my
uncle
i make like 2100 bucks or 1800 i can't
remember
come back for a month or two i spend
half of it on weed trying to re-up and
sell more weed to make money but i'm
spending on other drugs and i'm i'm down
to like 1100 bucks right or 1200. so my
little brother martin
once he's not really my blood my dad had
a
another family she had brady bunch he
had three kids she had three kids and
then they had three kids
so
i tell them hey i'm 14 i don't have a
license or a permit let's try to buy a
car there's got to be somebody out there
that's going to sell me a car
because i have the money i need to spend
it now or i'm never getting i'm just buy
drugs
so
i go to 82nd or 180 second two or three
car dealerships basically polite me told
me to get the [__] out of here i have a
stack in my pocket they don't know this
this little boy has a stack
and my little brother's three years
younger than me so i'm with a child with
spiky hair and then just me with long
uh no country for old men style hair
yeah that was me
and uh this old white man
i tell him like i'm looking for a car
and he goes all right
like all right kid he goes what are you
looking for i go i got 1200 bucks
and he looked at me this is the third
guy that turned me down go [__] this and
i pulled my money out to show him like
stop kicking me out of the [__]
dealerships guys because they were
telling me to get the [__] out
so i get i see this green dodge and trip
in 1996 dodge intrepid green [__] a
falcon looking car i love that car
i'm looking at him like oh it's nice i
don't know anything about cars like oh
yeah new tire i'm just trying to like
small talk so i can go by the way i'm
14. i didn't tell him that
but he goes to get his wife which owns
the park car lot with him
and then he tells her he doesn't have
his permit on him he forgot his id
that's why i told him like oh i forgot
my id can i still buy it
and um they did some illegalized [__]
she goes he's got money she goes then
[__] sell it to him they were old
like white couple smoking cigarette type
of
i know you know them right he's like
well [__] us out to him and she walks
back in he goes all right it's yours
all right twelve hundred dollars and he
goes but i need an id and proof of
insurance
are you [__] kidding me man you just
said you'll sell it to me so we my step
brother calls his mom she'll speak
spanish
and he tells her in spanish like hey we
need your id uh we're buying this car
but they need an adult and she [__]
gave it to us
like i don't know why she did this man
she trusted in us that you bought a car
at 14.
and then cash yep and then no insurance
on it right i had no money whatsoever
left and then my brother did you drive
it off the lot
i'm not even done yet i get in this car
i look at my brother and just oh [__]
you know that feeling of like get the
[__] out of here are you serious
i have like a couple dollars and ones
and change
right
oregon there's no taxes it was twelve
hundred dollars so i left with the car
i hit the little
and as soon as i do we both just start
screaming as loud as we can like how
have you ever driven before um everybody
in my family is truck drivers so i've
been driving so i was like six or five
like learning how to do the stick and my
dad would let me sit on his lap and then
when i turned eight he'd let me drive it
by myself very unprofessional and
unresponsible like
i'm a [__] child my dad's sitting
here twacked like yeah you [__] drive
yeah that's what's going on now that i
know so i know how to drive i can i
drive the moving truck i'm like you know
i know how to drive but we're also seven
eight miles from the house and i'm a
little nervous because we've been
clacking my switches on a mountain
so we were screaming like hitting each
other like no [__] way
we have a car insane we had enough money
for two spicy chicken sandwiches from
carl's jr
i pull up in the drive-through and i'm
trying i'm trying to look like no i'm
old enough and the guy's looking at me
like
and he gives me my
[__] i pull up and i get my food i'm
trying not to make eye contact with the
lady because she knows i'm a [__]
child i look like a young kid now i'm 32
now
so as a 14 year old i look a six ten
yeah with a [__] haircut
we're eating spicy chicken sandwiches i
remember i'm putting my ketchup on my
[__]
driving with one hand and i'm just
screaming like we have a [__] car
martin and i'm screaming to my brother
and he's looking at me like yo we just
[__] got a call
go to my house pull up my dad gets off
work a couple hours later he goes who's
cargo
they [__] sold me a car he goes no
they didn't no they didn't how'd you get
away i go
dad your wife gave me your id and then i
left the guy wanted that stack so bad he
goes hey child
[__] leave with the car off my
property kill yourself yes good thing he
sold it to somebody knew what they were
doing
but i remember my dad came home the look
of like
[__]
that i it was everything like yeah i
bought it and drove it home and chicken
sandwiches in it today like going
through the drive-through by yourself
was like the biggest so when you finally
got your license was that your card
because i stopped playing football and
the because my coach was a piece of [__]
i mean him got into it
and he's a driver's ed coach let me
drive he's a teacher oh no you [__] with
the wrong guy huh i didn't want to be in
the class i knew he'd film me we hated
each other like a mutual [__] you
but not saying [__] you in the hallway
all the time guy that quit football huh
wasted talent waste of time all the time
you would say that to me
because i quit
i
on some
days and confused [__]
your jersey's in there you know you're
the last guy that didn't get his pads
you go
i'll be there today but i was i had no i
no
motivation to play with for that guy
anymore [__] that guy
and um
so i didn't get my life since i was 18.
damn
so you drove illegally for four years
[__] yeah i was gonna say i know you
didn't just park the thing yeah i parked
at my grandma's but not left it
yeah i left it no i wasn't allowed to
take it out i didn't sneak it out when
my dad when my grandma was at work she's
a truck driver too that was my grandma's
a truck driver yeah my grandma my
grandma my uncles everybody
yeah my mom was everybody
so when they're not there oh i'm [__]
trying to do donuts because they're in
the country so we're in the cuts fields
uh just dirt and [__] so when they're
gone i mean they have diesel trucks they
have space to park
when they're gone i'm smoking weed in my
friend's house driving the back road a
mile parking smoking coming home like i
only use it for a couple minutes at a
time go get candy and [__] at the store
and come back when no one's looking
but
i i tried to jump it once because nobody
was home
and i [__] myself up
uh there's like a hill of my grandma's
i'm like yo 30 is good and i [__]
punched jesus right you hit it you
thirty you never do
the blues brother [__] you think you're
gonna [__] do that
i like that guy yeah
really hard and part of my dash [__]
fell off
you know like uh the center console part
yeah yeah and i'm looking around and all
the sensors are going off of my dash
and it's just when i try to get it back
into the park it goes
and i ruined my [__] car
that was a 16. that was the end of the
dodge and travel no no when i was 18 i
started driving it again and it was fine
wait
it just started working again i mean it
was grinding yeah but i used that for
pizza delivery for a year
yeah that was my first car ever man
this is a lot of fun man i appreciate
you coming back on and you have such an
interesting uh upbringing and very
different life than
i mean i'm sure than anybody you've
probably ever met a sister
outsider
she went through it will you promote
again everything you'd like please uh
yes dope's usual podcast
youtube spotify apple every single
monday at three o'clock we drop a new
episode oh you specifically do it at
three huh well it was five and then i
realized i'm missing monday night
football really [__] hard right now
can we move that [__] to three and then
it just did better because now people
are getting out of work going [__] i'm
missing the whole first half man can you
you know premiere it earlier so i can
get paid to watch your [__] at work
that's really what the comments were
like i'm at work i'm [__] bored can
you change the time so we did three
and that's really what we're doing man
just uh
job's usual podcast on monday at the
dopaziola channel
it's just weed [__] so if you like weed
[__] there it is and um
yeah that's really it that's everything
we're doing push trees
i have a new company coming out next
month
it's
it's legal cannabis
federally legal because it's under the
threshold so i can ship it to your
[__] door how's that
loopholes
legal loopholes is that real it's fed oh
it's real is it real marijuana though oh
edibles gummies but i mean it's not like
no it's not like weed or low level oh
it's oh oh so no flour no no [__]
because that [__] tastes like [__]
that low level thc is trash so we just
edibles got it but it's legal in all 50
states and i just i ate a thousand
milligrams the other day to see like if
it worked almost threw up my uber
yeah almost happened through the [__]
over man yeah i had to make sure it
worked and i was sitting there
regretting and i had to go to the
bathroom so i was like i'm gonna [__]
and throw up in this man's car
dude thank you for coming on man this
has been great it's a lot of fun
appreciate it man uh and as always uh
ryan sickler.com ryan sickler on all
your social media we'll talk to you all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
you